N
ASTROPHYSICIST BUT ACTUALLY HAS
COMMON SENSE.
THANKS SO MUCH.
ALSO HERE TONIGHT,
SENATOR TOM COTTON OF ARKANSAS.
SENATOR, YOU HURT US DISCUSS
THIS.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS BUDDIES MOVED
EVERYTHING OFF TO CHINA, AND NOW
IT IS A MESS BECAUSE OUR DESTINY
IS TIED UP WITH THE CHINESE.
ANYTHING HAPPENS IN CHINA
AFFECTS US LIKE A PANDEMIC, OR
A SUPPLY SHORTAGE.
AND JOE SAYING OH, I'M JUST
LEARNING ABOUT THIS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON
HERE?
>> JESSE, YOU PUT YOUR FINGER ON
THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM.
FOR 30 YEARS, WE HAVE SENT SO
MANY OF OUR JOBS AND
MANUFACTURING TO CHINA.
IT IS NOT EASY THESE DAYS TO BUY
A PIECE OF FURNITURE OR CLOTHING
OR SHOES OR TOYS FOR YOUR KIDS
ARE AT CHRISTMAS DECORATIONS
THAT DOES NOT COME FROM CHINA.
THAT HAS BEEN THE CASE FOR 30
YEARS.
JOE BIDEN HELPED CREATE THAT.
HE ALSO HELPED CREATE THE
SHORT-TERM PROBLEM BECAUSE OF
THE INFLATION THAT OUR COUNTRY
SEES DUE TO THE SUPPLY SHORTAGES
FROM HITTING PEOPLE NOT TO WORK,
LOCKING DOWN OUR ECONOMY, ALL OF
THIS WAS FORESEEABLE.
HE CELEBRATES TODAY THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO KEEP THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES OPEN 24 HOURS A DAY,
WHICH I PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN DOING MONTHS AGO, AT THE
SAME TIME THE WHITE HOUSE ARE
SAYING YOU ARE PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO GET EVERYTHING YOU WANT
FOR CHRISTMAS.
WHO IS GOING TO SAVE CHRISTMAS
FOR AMERICANS?
PETE BUTTIGIEG?
PLEASE.
PETE BUTTIGIEG CANNOT ORGANIZE A
ONE CAR FUNERAL, HE IS NOT GOING
TO ORGANIZE OUR NATION'S PORTS
AND RAILWAYS AND AIRPORTS.
>> Jesse: FAUCI SAID WE MIGHT
NOT EVEN BE ABLE TO CELEBRATE
CHRISTMAS, NOW THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYING NO TOYS UNDER THE TREE.
A DARK WINTER, HEY, ANOTHER
VARIANT COMING THROUGH THE NORTH
OF THE UNITED STATES, HOME
HEATING BILLS GOING TO BE
SKYROCKETING.
GOING TO BE A LOT OF UNHAPPY
AMERICANS IN THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS.
SENATOR COTTON, I GOT TO ASK, HE
SAID HE MADE SOME PHONE CALLS
TODAY FROM A JOE BIDEN GOT ON
THE PHONE, CALLED -- THAT HE IS
GOING TO CALL COMPANIES TO HIRE
MORE TRUCKERS.
DOES HE HEAR HOW SILLY THAT
SOUNDS?
HE CAN'T GET TRUCKERS BECAUSE NO
ONE IS WORKING BECAUSE OF ALL
THESE MANDATES AND FREE MONEY.
>> WELL, FOUR MONTHS, JESSE, THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT UNDER
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN PAYING PEOPLE
NOT TO GO TO WORK, THAT IS WHY
IT HAS BEEN SO HARD TO GET
WORKERS.
NOW JOE BIDEN IS THREATENING
PEOPLE, THREATENING TO FIRE
PEOPLE IF THEY WON'T GET A
VACCINE.
EVEN IF THEY HAVE HAD THE
CORONAVIRUS, EVEN IF THEY HAVE
NATURAL IMMUNITY.
AND AGAIN, HE IS ACTING
SURPRISEDDED THE SHORTAGE IS.
A ACTING LIKE THE PHOTO OP AT
THE WHITE HOUSE IS GOING SOLVE
IT.
THREE OR $4 FOR GAS, EXTRA $25 A
WEEK FOR THEIR GROCERIES.
ON THE BRIGHT SIDE THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO SPEND ON
CHRISTMAS TOYS UNDER JOE BIDEN'S
INFLATION, SO MAYBE IT'S NOT A
PROBLEM THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
TOYS ON THE SHELVES TO BUY IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
>> Jesse: WE TALKED ABOUT IT
AT THE TOP, AND THIS GUY HAS
NEVER RUN A BUSINESS,
HUNTER BIDEN IS HIS PORTFOLIO
MANAGER.
HUNTER IS IN CHARGE FOR
BALANCING YOUR CHECKBOOK, I
THINK THIS COUNTRY HAS A LOT OF
PROBLEMS.
YOU JUST LEARNED THE PRESIDENT
SHARED A BANK ACCOUNT, WE ONLY
KNOW OF ONE, WITH HIS SON.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE MONEY WAS
COMING FROM, THAT FOREIGN WIRES
ARE COMING THROUGH TO HUNTER,
AND JOE HAD ACCESS TO THAT
ACCOUNT.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO IS NOW IN
CHARGE OF A MULTITRILLION DOLLAR
ECONOMY, AND IT LOOKS LIKE THIS
RECOVERY IS STALLED OUT.
>> YEAH, THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
UNDER JOE BIDEN IS ABOUT AS
HEALTHY AND PRODUCTIVE AS
HUNTER BIDEN'S FINANCIAL LIFE.
MAY BE HUNTER BIDEN -- MAYBE HE
CAN MAKE SOME NEW PAINTINGS FOR
ALL AMERICANS FOR CHRISTMAS
GIFTS WHEN THEY CAN GET THE
TOYS.
>> Jesse: NO SUPPLY CHAIN
PROBLEMS THERE, RIGHT?
EVERYTHING IS JUST FLYING OFF
THE SHELVES AT THE GALLERY.
>> IT IS A SUPPLY CHAIN OF
CROOKED MONEY STRAIGHT INTO
HUNTER BIDEN'S POCKETS, AND NOW
WE KNOW THAT IS A LOT OF A BITE
AND FAMILY.
>> Jesse: WE KNEW THAT AND THE
MEDIA COVERED IT UP.
NOW HAS COME OUT BECAUSE WE KNEW
IT AND THEY STILL DON